foreign
X son of immigrants from a small Texas
border town
growing up I didn't have access to
classical music and I never been to the
symphony but I always knew that I wanted
to play a string instrument
so in sixth grade we got the opportunity
to pick our instruments for orchestra
class I took one look at the viola and
said great that'll work
and as I began to play the instrument I
immediately fell in love with it
even though my middle school orchestra
director was a fabulous space teacher
she could only teach me so much on the
viola and because there weren't any
Viola teachers in my town to be able to
play the things that I heard in my head
I turned to a teacher who seemed to know
everything
you too
by watching countless hours of YouTube
videos of the great virtuosos performing
everything from Beethoven to the musical
Suite from Star Wars
I tried to mimic their techniques and
incorporate them into my own playing
with a few difficult years of practice a
lot of Blood Sweat and Tears and the
endless support of an entire community
of people who really really wanted me to
succeed
I began to play at places that I've
never even dreamed of like Carnegie Hall
and bring my music to audiences across
four different continents it had been
one of the most difficult learning
experiences of my life
but one that proved an important point
anyone from anywhere can do incredible
things if you connect them with the
knowledge and resources that they need
to thrive
on my travels I became friends with the
elite Young Musicians who seem to have
all the resources because they live next
to musical capitals like New York
Chicago or L.A they set it at places
like Juilliard on the weekends they
watch their teachers perform major
symphony orchestras they had access to
almost every musical opportunity that
you can imagine right in their home
communities
and even though I was proud of the hard
work that I'd done to get to their level
I hated always feeling behind because I
never had access to private lessons
so you can imagine how excited I was
when I had the opportunity to take my
first professional private lesson with
one of the best violists in the world
I just knew he'd be so excited about how
much progress I made on my own and
encouraged me to become a professional
musician
so I came with such a surprise when he
told me to quit
he said kids like me who didn't start
playing at an early age who didn't have
access to private teachers and the best
resources we didn't really understand
how the classical music industry really
operated
generally could not make it as
professional musicians
now classical music is incredibly
competitive and sometimes people with
all the resources don't even make it so
I'm sure he thought he was doing me a
favor and maybe he was
but I was shocked it hurt
but I didn't want to disrespect him so I
smiled said okay and left
I was a 15 year old who loved playing
the viola more than anything but in that
moment I seriously considered putting my
instrument away forever
now I'm 21 years old and I couldn't be
more grateful to have experienced that
moment of discouragement
because it opened my eyes to the fact
that for 13 million children in the
United States who live outside of major
U.S cities pursuing a career in
something like classical music ballet
art research and many other historically
exclusive Fields is incredibly more
difficult if not practically impossible
In classical music for example
people of color make up only around 15
of America's orchestras despite
representing almost 42 percent of the
U.S population
so in some ways I don't blame that Viola
teacher for telling me to quit
music opportunities tend to Cluster
around major cities especially the
Charities and non-profits to try to help
underserved students and I just wasn't
around them
but people have talent everywhere and
everybody deserves a chance to grow that
talent and share it with the world
because when we allow people like me to
systemically be prevented from entering
into these competitive fields we uphold
the elitists and exclusionary systems
that allow so many children to be told
that they're not worthy enough to pursue
their dreams
I wanted to change that for many years I
had no clue how but when the covet
pandemic hit and our entire world went
virtual I saw an opportunity to help
others learn music online regardless of
who they were or they lived or what they
could afford
so I texted a few friends I knew from
around the country and put together a
founding team
together we reached out to 20 other
musicians that we knew and asked each of
them to teach a free virtual private
lesson a week to an underserved young
student
this meant that students like Samuel
Igbo a 14 year old violinist from a
small town in Texas who dreamed of
pursuing a career as a concert violinist
could receive personalized musical
mentorship from Nikki nagavi a
prize-winning violinist at the New
England Conservatory
my idea inspired and connected hundreds
of people from all walks of life to
offer their time and expertise to
aspiring and musicians like Sam from
around the country
and now just two and a half years later
this little idea has turned into through
the staff a national non-profit that has
provided almost six hundred thousand
dollars of free virtual private lessons
to almost a thousand Young Musicians
from Fresno California to Wilkesboro
North Carolina
I didn't realize it but I'd accidentally
started a virtual non-profit we didn't
just use the internet to deliver our
services our organization existed on the
internet
because our program was run entirely by
volunteers from around the country
who work together for a common cause
despite never meeting once in person
because our students and teachers could
learn from each other online wherever
they were Geographic boundaries no
longer mattered
digital workspace meant virtually no
startup or scaling costs so we've been
able to grow and make incredible changes
with a budget of only nine thousand
dollars over two and a half years
it was only after I began to see his
profound potential for impact that I
realized that virtual organizations can
help us better distribute educational
resources directly to those who have
benefit from them the most
and if this worked in classical music I
figured it can work in other places too
this time in academic research
when I began to explore biological
research in my second year of college I
remember trying to find a mentor and
being discouraged to only see white male
researchers
just like in music this trend is
systemic
only 15 of all doctoral researchers were
Native American
African-American Or Hispanic I wanted to
change that and I knew that the virtual
non-profit model that I had already
developed could make a difference here
too
I could start something that could help
generations of future young researchers
break into Academia
so in 2021 my best friend and I gathered
a founding team of 31 college students
and started another virtual non-profit
called the pre-college research
institute
together we've created four 32-hour
virtual research courses that have
taught trained and inspired 160 high
school students of color from clerksdorp
South Africa to New Delhi India
to Alpharetta Georgia
if I could break down barriers and
access to music and academic research
anyone can do it anywhere
that's exactly what makes virtual
nonprofits so powerful
they transcend Geographic boundaries and
bring opportunities to those who would
literally never otherwise have them
they're a new way to find and connect
the world to a huge source of untapped
talent and a necessary step to nurturing
the future of these industries
the future that will not only change the
fabric of these institutions but ensure
they survive and prosper for years to
come
and as more and more children are
connected to the opportunities and
knowledge and resources that they need
to chase their dreams
I'm excited to see the people that lead
every industry look a lot more like the
world around them I know that this
transformation can happen but I can't do
it alone
so if you have an idea or interest for
how to make a historically inaccessible
field more equitable
grab a few friends
brainstorm a way that you can break down
the barriers in your field
and start a virtual non-profit you may
never meet the majority of the people
that you serve but the effects of your
hard work will touch them in ways that
they will never forget
thank you
[Applause]